hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival okay we got no time to waste
we're going into the abyss and I've kind
of felt like I've missed some of the
collectable pages I'm not exactly sure
so I'm gonna focus less on that and more
on just completing the challenge that
lies before me in that I'm probably
going to die a lot all right so we're
gonna make our way slowly not wasting
our flashlights at all make our way
slowly into the abyss and I don't know
why my frame rate is so low at the
moment hopefully that's gonna even out
hello game what the hell you're acting
like my computer suddenly took a dump
all over itself but that is not the case
might as well grab the ones that are on
the way just give myself something to do
maybe my maybe my computer Tron can't
handle all of this glorious foliage in
all of its amazing 720p okay alright
that should be enough for the things
that I'm gonna grab and I'm not even
gonna waste my flashlight going into
here eyeballs off this I did not want
this I didn't ask for this I asked for a
flashlight in my brain but I didn't get
what I needed
here we go oh boy okay so since since I
now know the technique with the focusing
of the beams I must first pick up a gas
canister Oh Oh know what that is
I wear uh oh uh oh okay
ah come on that's not fair that's a fair
at all I gotta pick up gas canisters -
this is such baloney right I don't need
it just walk very calmly collectively
and I guess I'm looking for gas
canisters - and I bet I can only carry
one at a time cuz that would just be
fancy Foley magical all right oh this is
gonna be rough but I am a professional
and I will continue until my eyeballs
bleed cuz that's how I roll [ __ ] yeah
okay I don't see gas canister AHA I see
gas canister
oh man I'm already out of sprint okay
here's another one so that's three gas
canisters right here that's what that
sounded like
I guess I'll go down no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no ah another
one I I can carry more than one at a
time well I guess that makes it a little
bit better and I've already got three
canisters so this is going pretty well
not too shabby I think I might even be
able to survive this just got to be sure
to check all the nooks and crannies cuz
it looks like the gas canisters can be
just about everywhere
sous-sous let me check the back rooms
and oh my god my sprint has died
suddenly I went from being Olympic
runner to absolutely nothing
god I'm awful oh look at me go come on
Laura
come on use your legs I know you got
powerful legs now use them oh here we go
there's no gas canister in here all
right
two of six on a roll I'm gonna win oh
yeah 306 oh yeah for sex I'm doing great
I'm doing flippin amazingly I need to
find more gas canisters where are you
where I ah
is that the pitter-patter of young
footsteps I hear where be a better I
better really focus on conserving my
flashlight huh uh you're behind me
somewhere
ah-ha Wow hot see Slendy where is he
and where's the little dick if that is
Kate where is she where is she where's
my friggin gas canisters going in a
circle now oh that's bad don't be around
this corner don't be around this corner
that's better
I'm a circle around this way because
there's another level of the gas
canisters that I think I missed I've
already got four or six the only thing
that's hindering me is my finding of gas
canisters which might prove to be a bit
more difficult than I have previously
imagined
oh no my this isn't oh this isn't a
different area this is just downstairs
where I was okay anyway let's go this
way I'll loop back around while at the
same time hopefully picking up a few
more gas canisters ha where are ya now
thank you super speed super speed Abdo
pro do pro look at me go to pro and
either I need to go up on that catwalk
where where is a high see you back there
alright you're way off I'll get you in a
second sky bear ski yeah there we go
run ah okay there's another thing but I
don't have another gas canister hot
right there yes how convenient
yes five I'm the best ah I hear you
another gas canister yes
nope you f off F so far off gimmi gimmi
gimmi gimmi gimmi thank you thank you
now where is the last a gas thing I have
no idea probably maybe down there I
don't know I have no idea but let me try
to go across this catwalk maybe I'll
find something else on the way
it's just one more generator and I don't
know where it is
hi ah no oh you [ __ ] I need to go that
way no no no no no b-block [ __ ] yeah
that's right slender f off not today not
today not tomorrow oh yeah oh yeah oh
hell yeah I know you don't little [ __ ]
Kate you think you're too Pro but you're
actually less pro than you thought cuz
I'm about to win I'm doing great
are you doing terribly oh that's
fantastic I'm so glad to hear it come on
come on Laura come on pick it up come on
just dig deep into your loins and start
pumping as hard and fast as you can with
your leg muscles or take immunity what
the hell what you gotta be [ __ ] me
what a friend so mad I'm doing the robot
what the hell are you kidding me what
the [ __ ] I was right there bread head oh
that son oh man that is as the biggest
slice of [ __ ] pie I've ever seen in
my life
screw it that is such baloney you're
kidding me
you're freaking kidding me oh my god I
am so angry are the are hopefully the
gas cans are in the same place cuz these
who are in the same place oh man that is
such bull oh I'm so angry I don't sound
angry but I'm angry I am thoroughly
upset at that ah man that's the second
time they robbed me right when I was
right there they robbed me there's a
singing come ere you [ __ ] all right
I've got one gas canister I need three
more gas canisters and for more
generators oh oh oh I bet you all
thought that I was gonna get it right
down there cuz I sure did where are you
see this takes less time than I thought
so I might not need to turn off my
flashlight as much as I have been okay
where were those gas canisters I have
forgotten
I hear the pitter-patter of young feet
AHA oh oh I thought where are you oh
[ __ ] I don't have one
I need another oh there you are
ah you super speed thank you yes okay if
if if the gas canisters are in the same
place and I I don't know if they are but
I need to circle back to that generator
somehow uh oh here's one okay they're
not in the same place there's just a few
places that they can be whoa oh I think
I see one Oh
eagle eyes eagle eyes Oh
sculpt that one from across the room to
prowl I think it's just one more gas
canister and I'll be done with the
canisters
let's see should I go left or right I'll
go up first and then circle back down
later if Slenderman wasn't a such a
giant oh you [ __ ]
you mother mother booping' booping'
booping' pooper up Wow where'd you come
from what the hell I there's no way that
I'll never mind now got a crawl from
like a broken leg or something I don't
know I don't know what she does to me
but here's the last canister okay I got
a circle back and hit that one generator
that was oh can I get to it from up here
I don't think so oh here's another
generator okay this is is this a second
or last one yeah then I just got to go
get the last generator which is
downstairs
oh man I'm closer than I thought I know
you don't you [ __ ] you're not getting
the Johno how you got to jump on me like
that I'm so focused on Slendy that you
are just I'm pain in the balls what what
that Oh what that what that I hear but
that's a sound of a douche oh that's the
sound of the yellow-breasted douche
McGill ER and Slendy don't even [ __ ]
with me right now I'm still mad at you
I'm still mad at you Slendy because
you're a giant pain in the balls okay
where was it it was down here this way
I'll get away from me why don't I have
bursts of speed gah
where is he where is he I see you I see
you way over there oh no uh-uh yeah
wait where's the where's oh come on come
on you just stay there you will [ __ ]
Kate don't even think about it
oh come on burst of speed come on come
on come on come on get out get out get
out come on don't no no no no no no no
oh yeah Burgess speed yes come on
Slendy don't be a [ __ ] ah it was so
scary I got a sudden burst of speed out
of that all the adrenaline is just
killing me come on where are you all
right come on come on hurry the [ __ ] up
where are you where are you
yes yes suck on that Slendy and Kate
what if you are proxy you're such a
[ __ ] okay don't fall here if I fall
here I'm so pissed okay wait till it's
officially done
come on stable ground let's go go go go
go go yes yes ah I'm champion I'm the
greatest Wow Wow ah I'm the best ever
okay cool cool beans we're making
progress I'm actually doing well on
hardcore you all thought that I'd y'all
if sled me wasn't such a pain in the ass
and such a cheating bastard I would have
gotten that way earlier so anyway we'll
finish this up in the next one I think
uh we'll see
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more video City
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
love